katia le cortège est arrivé du côté de
la place de la nation c'est bien sûr oui
absolument il est arrivé dans le calme
il s'est dispersé dans le calme pour le
moment il reste encore des manifestantes
yves échanges mais pour le moment rien à
signaler et un cortège qui a compté
plusieurs milliers de personnes
aujourd'hui une mobilisation
interprofessionnelle à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale fsu cgt solidaires et
de quatre organisations de jeunesse il
plaidé aujourd'hui pour la défense du
service public et la création d'emplois
quand on sait que le contexte est morose
1 85 mille rupture de contrat en janvier
alors il demande l'arrêt des
suppressions d'emplois la titularisation
des contractuels et d'autres
revendications je vous propose d'écouter
avec les interventions de philippe
martinez secrétaire général de la cgt et
benoît thèse secrétaire général de la
fsu il faut que la colère on croise tous
les jours qu'il y a dans les entreprises
elles puissent exprimer donc c'est un
appel à dire oh il faut que nos
revendications sont attendus la santé ça
fait des années que ça dure
mais est-ce qu'on tire les leçons de la
période où est-ce qu'on continue à
fermer des lits dans l'éducation
léon on continue à supprimer les emplois
en efficacité dans l'éducation et les
services publics
et puis dans les entreprises on parle de
relancer le gouvernement a dit pour
lancer le ferroviaire le fret
les trains de nuit bah c'est des
milliers d'emplois ça donc il ya des tas
d'endroits où on peut créer des emplois
la situation elle est compliquée pour le
service public parce que on a le
sentiment que tout le monde est dans des
préoccupations très immédiates mais qu'
on n'est pas en train de préparer
l'avenir et par exemple si je vous donne
un exemple on est en train de supprimer
des postes dans les collèges et les
lycées de personnels enseignants mais
aussi en crée pas de nouveaux postes de
personnels éducatifs d'agents
territoriaux etc et donc on est en train
de auber et l'avenir de de gâcher
l'avenir et pour la prochaine rentrée on
ne va pas avoir suffisamment de profs et
de personnel en face des élèves à une
époque où il faudrait au contraire
investir dans l'éducation
donc la mobilisation était plutôt
fournie à un compte tenu du contexte
sanitaire on attendait peut-être moins
deux personnes et finalement il en a eu
peut-être jusqu'à vers 1100 tout cas ce
sont les chiffres des syndicats ce qui
est une
disons en ce moment de pandémie a plutôt
un exploit mais il faut dire que parmi
les syndicalistes la colère et
l'engagement reste intacte merci
catch-up technique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc du cortège
parisien